game of thrones was infamous for its
violence and its sex scenes but house of
the dragon looks to change that how keep
watching spoilers ahead throughout its
original run game of thrones subjected
its female characters to assault abuse
and scary sexual encounters now the
first episode of house of the dragon
available to stream questions about
whether or not the spin-off series will
follow in these controversial footsteps
are starting to be asked at first when
addressing questions about how house of
the dragon would approach sex scenes
showrunners miguel sapochnick and ryan
conval stirred up controversy with
comments they made to the hollywood
reporter sapochnick claimed that there
would be less sexual violence but that
they would make the show as accurate as
possible to the source material at the
time sapochnick told the outlet that
they would approach sexual violence
carefully thoughtfully and we don't shy
away from it if anything we're going to
shine a light on that aspect you can't
ignore the violence that was perpetrated
on women by men in that time it
shouldn't be downplayed and it shouldn't
be glorified the comments immediately
made waves on social media with fans and
critics alike bemoaning the fact that
house of the dragon would just be more
of the same when it came to graphic
depictions of sexual assault however in
comments apochenic and combo have made
sense it seems that they are trying to
approach things more sensitively in a
roundtable with pop sugar the
showrunners walked back their remarks a
bit saying i think for whatever reason i
think something was incorrectly reported
or got misconstrued we're very aware of
the time that we live in we're very
aware of how different the world is now
versus 10 years ago when the original
show premiered condole did note that sex
and violence are a part of the framework
of any game of thrones property however
saying
it's game of thrones there is sex and
violence as part of the story the
particular way that we've approached it
in this time is making sure that
whenever you're going to have any kind
of sex or violence on screen that
there's a compelling story reason for it
and that it's a story that needs to be
told it's not being done gratuitously or
to titillate or anything like that to
add to that condole specifically noted
that the show is now employing intimacy
coordinators and actors were rehearsing
scenes in advance to feel as comfortable
as possible adding and i think they felt
very good about it because they knew as
actors that they were performing a story
and not doing sex for sexist sake in the
first episode of house of the dragon the
series already showcases the sexual
content for which the original was known
prince damon targaryen has a sex scene
with his lover and companion mazaria and
he also arranges an orgy where a couple
stops mid-act to listen to him give a
speech about being next in line from the
throne there's also an unsettling
implication that damon and his niece
princess rhaenyra targaryen might share
a sexual attraction the show also pulls
back in several instances suggesting
rather than showing while a pregnant
queen emma takes a bath to soothe her
aching body her body is hidden in the
water you spend more time in that bath
than i do on the throat
this is the only place i can find
comfort these days after emma dies in
childbirth and leaves her husband
serious in a state of grief allison
hightower goes to his chambers to
comfort him though it's still unknown
whether or not allison and viserys
consummated their relationship the show
hints at it rather than beating the
audience over the head with a
potentially unsettling sex scene only
time will tell whether or not house of
the dragon approaches its sex scenes
with restraint or recklessness but
audiences are certainly hoping for more
sensitivity where these very delicate
sequences are concerned
if you or someone you know is dealing
with domestic abuse you can call the
national domestic violence hotline at
1-800-799-7233
you can also find more information
resources and supports at their website
[Music]